On the next Rick and Morty hey Morty
hold on watch this
uh-huh
Well I thought it was cool so it should
be in and out simple exchange not even
really an adventure and if anything goes
wrong which it won't, jump into the same
vat of acid I jump into. Okay wait wait
what catch a new episode next Sunday at
11:30 I have English homework. You're still
learning English it's the language you
speak how dumb are you only on Adult
Swim.
Glorzo is peace, Glorzo is law. All is Glorzo!
it's the saddest alien species in
the world like it's very much like a
dodo bird
Morty relax their face hugging parasites
we always referred to it as the Starro
episode which I think was a DC Comics
thing I always figure if you're biting
something just bite it and tell you have
to change it so that you know exactly
what you're changing and why that is
called responsibility at a certain point
we thought what have we just did
nonlinear storytelling which as far as I
know is like a first for us. Last thing I remember I
was in a cave looking at some wet egg oh
that probably did it when they wake up
they have to go through her and kind of
piece together what happened to them
let's lick this after they caused a lot of destruction
and by a lot of destruction I mean so
much destruction.
Some of the parts were like uncomfortable
working on the episode.
They're the stock bad guys of every
movie like in a Star Wars movie you feel
completely fine m*rdering thousands of
stormtroopers you don't think about it
but then we just wanted to switch that
to like humanize these evil aliens I
always wondered does the face hugger
have dreams of its own in a sea of chaos
and tragedy and death we wanted to have
just this one brief moment of connection
are we allowed to do this I don't care I
just want you. Love and connection is
all we have so we have to value that can
we have a family yeah.
It's dark it gets dark.
Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is going to be
my Rick and Morty season 4 episode 8
trailer video we also have a clip of
them talking about season 5 stuff so
I'll play the clip in a second but if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter-egg
videos we're doing a Rick and Morty
merch giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions for the VAT of asset
episode which is basically what episode
8 is going to be that's all it's titled
the one with the vat of acid this is the
season 5 clip of Chris Parnell who plays
Jerry talking about what's going on with
the season 5 episodes.
We have not started recording season 5 but I know
that they certainly episodes written and
you know have it boarded to a certain
extent but I don't know when we'll start
recording I've upgraded my home set up
even though it doesn't look like it I've
upgraded it so I can actually record
proper sessions from home you know as
long as the studio does like you know
some safety protocols and and stuff like
that it's it's an easy sort of situation
to go into a booth and record and not
really have to encounter anybody you
know but yeah I haven't even started
recording yet for season 5.
So IGN was
doing an interview with him about
seperate stuff and during that interview
they talked about what's going on with
season 5 surprise update on season 5
episodes it was done a little while ago
at the time he said that they had not
started recording their voice over
dialogue and normally people would freak
out saying wait a minute how are we
going to get episodes later this year if
they haven't started
their voice over dialogue but that's
only on the normal schedule that they
used to have their production on before
the virus shut everything down a couple
months ago the virus delayed pretty much
all TV and movies that people were
working on right now but animation has
actually kind of been an exception
because most animators can actually work
from home the biggest thing that most
animated series have had trouble with
right now is actually getting the
voice-over actors into a booth somewhere
to record their dialogue.
You guys are teaching me a very dangerous lesson.
that I don't need to be sober to record the voices.
So as you sees chris parnell says during
this video most of them have either
started recording their lines remotely
from their home studios if they have
them or in the case of people like chris
parnell constructing small recording
spaces inside their houses during the
quarantine so it sounds like the Rick
and Morty stuff that's been delayed the
most has just been the voice over
dialogue and it's way easier to turn
that part of the production process
around faster than the actual raw
animation the animation is typically
what takes the longest to do on Rick and
Morty just last week I posted a big long
video of the animators talking about why
exactly it takes them so long to make
the show and it's all about how complex
Rick and Morty animation is compared to
other more primitive looking animated
series like Family Guy or South Park
South Park is probably the best example
because they turn episodes around in
under a week because of the way they
animate the series the animation on Rick
and Morty is so hardcore that it usually
takes them more like five to six months
to turn an episode around so we're still
on track to get season five episodes or
at least the first half of season five
by the end of the year worst possible
case scenario is that they do wind up
delaying the first half of Rick and
Morty season 5 to spring next year but
instead of breaking the season into two
halves like they did with season four
they just air all 10 episodes
back-to-back so I don't think that
people really care about that as long as
they get new episodes on a relatively
normal schedule but in the trailer for
season 4 episode 8 Rick has that joke
about the auto parking function in his
spaceship that's a Tesla joke Justin
roiland and Dan Harmon are friends with
Elon Musk in real life that's all
so part of the reason why Elan musk
wound up having the Cameo seen during
the Rick and Morty season for heist
episode we need your help Rick Morty
why me if you don't follow Dan Harmon on
Instagram back when people still went
outside before the virus he bought
himself a Tesla and would drive around
filming himself in it all the time just
because he loved the tech so much I love
that Morty is completely unimpressed
with this tech though Rick kind of
breaks the fourth wall when describing
the mission of the episode in and out
super quick not even enough stuff is
supposed to happen for it to qualify is
an actual Rick and Morty adventure
oh no yeah not that anything would go
wrong but if it does just be sure to
jump into the same vat of acid that I do
then proceeds to drag Morty for being so
dumb because he has to study the
language that he speaks English even
though that's not exactly why people in
America or at least Americans take
English classes usually kids who speak
English in America take English classes
to learn how to write better stories or
to study the history of the language
there's a couple other clips from this
episode from the other Rick and Morty
season 4 trailer there's them trying to
trade these jewels to another alien in
some shady looking deal for something
surrounded by what looks like a
warehouse full of vats of acid which
also curiously enough look kind of like
the green portal fluid that Rick uses
which they then fall into so maybe when
Rick says jump into the same vat of acid
that I do during the trailer he's
actually talking about a big trick that
he pulls where he shoots his portal gun
into one of the vats so it's actually
them jumping into a portal it just looks
like they're jumping into a vat of acid
after watching the last couple of Rick
and Morty trailers then getting the
actual episodes we've learned that
they're actually very misleading with
their trailer footage almost nothing
goes down the way it seems in the
trailers then I love when they're
talking about episode 7 Dan Harmon says
that they called the episode the Storrow
episode before they gave it to
Prometheus reference for the official
title the funny thing about that is that
Adult Swim is owned by Cartoon Network
and Cartoon Network is owned by Warner
Media which also owns DC Comics so
technically they're all part of the same
company so there wouldn't be any kind of
issue with them doing more obvious DC
Comics parodies they probably just went
with the primordius Prometheus reference
for the title because it worked better
with Morty's name and they had the
egg-laying repre
and even though Starro attaches copies
of itself to people's faces controlling
them like parasites it doesn't lay eggs
Marduk the demigod and Ishtar his
daughter raged against the star
creatures in a battle for all mankind
that shook the walls of Babylon
if you're not a big DC fan all that
Starro footage came from Young Justice
season 3 they had some pretty top-tier
animation all that stuff is coming to
HBO max along with Rick and Morty
episodes I don't know exactly what their
plan is for syndicating Rick and Morty
on the HBO max service but that's
basically Warner Brothers new streaming
service that's the answer to Disney Plus
that's not launching till later this
month but you don't absolutely have to
get that service just to get Rick and
Morty episodes it's just an extra way to
get episodes along with all of Warner
Brothers other TV and movie content my
full episode 8 Easter eggs video will
post next Monday just like normal
there's a bunch of stuff that's
happening this week so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all the videos when I post
them but leave all your Rick and Morty
video requests in the comments below and
any big questions that you want me to
add to my next video congratulations
squit me you're the giveaway winner from
my last big Rick and Morty video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so that I can get your details
everyone click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 7 video and click
here for my brand new Justice League
Apokolips War movie video thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!